it's funny when your kids
start doing [ __ ] to you
that you did to your father i had this
conversation with my son i called him
into my room one day i go hey man
and he goes what's up
i said
you know
that
vodka doesn't freeze
and he said i didn't know that i
actually didn't know that i had zero
idea that that was a thing until
i don't know this was probably the
learning curve did you know
that
water
does
and he said i did know that i go really
then
why is my vodka frozen
you dumbass like what
why do i have a popsicle in my freezer
in all honesty i was just looking out
for you man because you know sometimes
you gotta ration your liquor with your
water so you're not hungover you know
what i'm saying look we all stole booze
from our parents right but at least i
was creative about it i used to put
apple juice on the patio for two weeks
right so it would ferment so when i put
it back in my dad's bottle it smelled
like whiskey
to this day my dad's like man
i can't drink that whiskey it gives me
the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i feel like
drinking two-week-old
porch apple juice
might do more to your system than just
make you [ __ ] so i told my son i was
like listen man i can't have you
stealing things from me you want to know
what something tastes like you're old
enough we can sit down and living room
and taste it and he was like okay i've
never had beer before
and i said okay so i went out and i
bought us a case of beer
and um i was sitting there and i go look
at this well like gentlemen we're having
a beer together and and most important
thing is we're safe right buddy lesson
number one is you never
drink and drive
and then i got him
booking [ __ ] base right
he would finish a beer i'm like shotgun
he's like what's shotgun
quick interjection right there i know
how much we joke around about you know
everything that we do but my dad always
told me and it's a firm thing i believe
in every day drinking and driving is not
funny you not only put yourself at risk
but other people on the road for
everybody's safety out there your
families yourself and all those out
there please don't drink and drive i
murdered him all right and he passed out
on the ground so i shaved one of his
eyebrows
and then i drew a dick on his cheek
right here
because you never pass out first stupid
welcome to the world daddy loves you it
took me eight hours to get that sharpie
off my face and the eyebrow i'm gonna
make it even grew back it'd be crazy if
one of these was like a prosthetic and i
just ripped it off completely it was
just bare just trying to teach him one
lesson at a time my friends you know
what i mean i'm only one man i'm only
one man
is that how you teach your kids lessons
i don't know i feel like that's a page
out of the book i won't be taking from
josh wolfe not getting my son hammered
for his first time drinking beer i do
have another story though so after that
i learned my lesson and so instead of
just taking some out of the bottle
i figured i'd just take the whole bottle
you know so i did but so at this time my
dad was on chelsea lately and she you
know had a
endless supply of belvedere
vodka you know she just handed them out
like they were hugs right it was crazy
and so
we had a bunch of spare bottles
in the garage
and so
i figured i'd just you know
indiana jones this [ __ ] and take one
bottle and replace it with another and i
figured it would work now while i'm
saying that out loud i wondered why i
just didn't take one out of the garage
because that seems like it would have
just been way easier
right and so i ended up taking this
whole bottle
and swiping it out
with uh with a completely
other bottle and ended up keeping this
bottle in my sock drawer for i don't
know
probably six months maybe even longer i
just held on to the vodka because
at this point in time i tried it but i
wasn't really for it but i'm also then
not going to put the bottle back because
then they go well where's this bottle
been i'll be like
i don't know where it was i just kind of
found it
that's going to ruin myself there so
that would just be the end so i just
held onto it
and then after a while i just put the
bottle back exactly where i took it from
no one has said a word to this day so
surprise so if you can't just take a
little kids just take the whole bottle i
don't know if that applies to everything
but take that in moderation
we'll see you next time
[Music]
bye
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]